stephen strasburg scheduled a pitch
tonight scratch from his start
and so eric fetty will start in his
place tonight so
two errors here in the first inning
those are the
official scorers rulings and the ball
hit by le mayhew and the ball that was
tattooed by
torres and it's two on with one out
and stanton licking his chest two on
pitch his grounded left side
might be second and on
first what a job by eric fetty to get
around
two errors in the emergency start
so the big maple is on the mound he had
i guess an okay first half he was
brilliant in the second half
and that led him to a 15-6 record an
era of 3.82 two men away here in the
bottom of the first inning will bring up
starlin castro who's looking for his
first hit as a national
here's one into right center field this
ball is well
hit judge is there but can't make the
catch
off the bottom of the wall and castro
will dig around
second and cruise into third with a two
out triple here in the first
judge went back as far as he could jump
but just missed it
and it banged off the wall and banged
toward the infield
kendrick a terrific line drive righty
hitter
swung on and line to center field and
making the catches hicks
as the ball started to take off so
paxton pitches through the triple
the bases are loaded cabrera at third
suzuki at second
and kibum at first as the nationals have
three hits in the inning
so now robles who was all for two on
opening ninth
one run will score that's as drupal
cabrera
here comes suzuki and holding it third
is ki boom on a two-run double by victor
robles and the nationals are on top two
nothing in the second
taylor 250 and a limited roll last year
88 at bats
inside of the backstop that's ball four
aaron boone's coming out that's going to
be it
wow paxton he has struggled and unable
to get an out
here in the second inning he's done
michael king kid from boston college who
made his first opening day roster is in
and king deals 1-0 there's a chopper to
short
flip it to second one on to first double
play
the run scores from third that's kaboom
and washington takes a three-nothing
lead that run charged of course
to paxton michelle at third with one man
out
washington with a three-nothing lead
does not bring the infield in
fetty deals and the pitches line to left
center field as a base hit
the run scores it's a base hit and an
rbi
for la mayhew and the yankees trail
three to one
yankees are trailing three to one and
giancarlo will lead it up and that ball
is just tattooed stanton hits it to the
back
of that tarp in left field and this is a
one
run game and john smoltz i mean you just
can't hit a ball any harder
hit against that tarp might have broken
a seat out there if the tarp wasn't on
it
well him and mr judge are dominating the
statcast era on exit velocity and
distance they basically have a strong
hold
run on and one man out here's victor
robles
roblox a high drive down the left field
line hooking toward the corner this one
is deep will it stay fair it's way back
there and it hits the foul pole
shades of howie kendrick victor robles
doinks one off the left field foul pole
in the corner for a two run homer
and the nationals lead it five to two so
victor robles has a double a home run
and four rbis
you're in game two in 2020. so one on
one out and here is
howie kendrick and the o2 swing and a
drive to center field deep
back goes hicks way back it's over his
head and bounces over the center field
wall
scores eaton from third and the
nationals now lead by
four six to two howie kendrick with his
first hit of the year
an extra base hit as drubal cabrera
switching to batting left
with kendrick at second one out one in
washington with a 6-2 lead
swinging a line right field toward the
line that's a base hit him by a diving
judge to the fence
kendrick around third can walk on home
and in the second
goes as drupal cabrera aaron judge
taking the chance and the sinking
lighter made the dive couldn't get it
cabrera with the rbi double drives in
his first run
of the year with the extra base hit as
dribbles had a good game
two hits and three times up plus an rbi
the one two is driven to deep right
field
sending judge back on the run to the
warning track looking up and this one is
gone
as drupal cabrera clears the big wall in
right center field for his first home
run of the season
and the nationals lead it eight to two
as cabrera has his third hit
and second rbi of the ball game
here's michael taylor blasting on a deep
left field way back
going going and gone goodbye
that one hits the tarp atop the seats in
section 102 and
bounces up onto the center field plaza
michael taylor has his first home of the
year
well here's judge he's over four grounds
one to short
might be could be it is the ball game
and good work by kyle finnegan who's got
a smile on his face as the nationals
take this game and both teams are one
and one